ciao maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo video
l'idea del video di oggi mi é venuta perché stavo rovistando nel cassettone di camera mia
dove butto tutte le cose che non so dove
mettere che creano disordine e ho
trovato queste carte le ho ritrovate e
ho detto facciamo assolutamente subito
il video
indovinalo con delle emoji ma in che
senso indovinalo con delle emoji
spieghiamo meglio come funzionano queste carte allora sono 56 56 cards aspettate
che perdo i pezzi dove qui davanti
nel diciamo riquadro giallo appunto
troviamo le emoji dietro c'è un riguardo
un riquadro rosso dove troviamo
diciamo la soluzione del rebus quindi
cosa significano quelle emoji messe
insieme
ho pensato di fare una challenge per
fare una challenge non é che mi metto qua e le
indovino da sola ci vuole minimo
un'altra persona no ed è qui che farei
entrare lo special guest di oggi edo
che da dietro la telecamera
la videocamera mi arriva davanti per
fare con me questa challenge bellissima
dove ovviamente ci sarà un vincitore
perché spieghiamolo meglio come
giocheremo ad occhi chiusi ognuno di noi
pescherà dal mazzo che avrà in mano
l'altro una carta e la consegnerà
all'altra persona
ovviamente chi deve indovinare vedrà
solo il riquadro giallo
chi invece c'è dietro la carta vedrà la
risposta quindi il riquadro rosso e
ognuno di noi ha disposizione può
chiedere per ogni diciamo carta da
indovinare un consiglio già le regole
non le sappiamo edoardo iniziamo male in più ognuno
di noi avrà a disposizione due aiuti da
casa mi sembra di essere un pó al
milionario questi due aiuti da casa la indovino con una
no quello era sarabanda due aiuti da casa che possono essere o
una chiamata o un messaggio a una
persona un amico fidanzato eccetera
eccetera oppure chiederlo ai propri
follower su instagram con la box delle
domande partiamo subito allora tieni le
card pari o dispari non facevo queste
cose da tantissimi anni vai pari ok
quindi inizi tu a indovinare ok ok
allora aspetta facciamola vedere
ovviamente a tutti guarda allora un ape
on e un'onda cioé proprio guarda veramente la
ma l'ape è proprio l'ape non
puoi dire ape on
eccetera eccetera come si dice ape in
inglese bee beyoncé cioé capito l'ha indovinata subito
adesso a me toccherà quella difficilissima posso vedere vai neve e scimmiette è un film no è un gruppo
musicale artic monkeys un bambino un anello un
dragon ball aspetta no non è la mia
risposta definitiva
eh no no no no no l'hai detta no l'hai detta
l'hai detta sbagliata dragonball no l'hai detta
é sbagliata allora le regole le abbiamo
spiegate all'inizio la dici sbagliata ed é
sbagliato era facilissima pure questa lo hobbit
immaginavo infatti ha detto drago ball è
facile allora ma questa é facilissima
facilissima dai su é quello che
penso io è uno dei miei film preferiti
twilight
aspetta devo farla vedere allora è facile se
sai la risposta no però posso dire in
realtà secondo me è facile guarda è
facile anche la cosa potrebbe essere il
titolo di un film non te lo posso dire
perché vuoi chiedere solo una volta la
categoria one way che cos'è una canzone
ragazzi era facile qui potevi chiedere
l'aiuto te lo dicevano subito one
direction cioè dai raga facilissimo e vabbè
che centra però uno e freccia era
direzione anche questa é facilissima dai
é un altro dei miei film preferiti no vabbè ragazzi la bella e la bestia e qui ci sta la canzone
- - -
questa non ne ho la piú pallida idea non guardare
due uomini e un bambino
due genitori e mezzo
c'eri quasi two and a half men due
uomini e mezzo e che film é non lo so vabbè cultura
generale andremo a vederlo questa qui
vabbè allora questa ma posso vedere
direi aspetta direi facilina non
facilissima ma facilina vai guarda
letteralmente proprio x men x e
tre uomini che è men facile
aspetta facciamo perché devo farla vedere
questa è bellissima questa la so red hot
chili peppers cantami una canzone dei red hot
- - -
questa non facilissima fa vedere fa vedere
aereo letto più cibo si
bed and breakfast allora ti faccio no faccio finta di non aver sentito e ti dó un aiutino
che buono che é edo io gliel avrei già data sbagliata
allora aereo letto é un'app airbnb vabbe piu o meno bed and breakfast non era difficile
facile facilissima
guarda é un telefilm non te lo posso dire ma più di tre
secondi non ci puoi mettere
proprio easy house of cards a me
capitano sempre quelle un po difficili
difficilissimo questa é difficile allora no è
molto attuale come carta america uomo
tromba
american trumpet ah no no oddio lo so
donald trump american trumpet non si poteva sentire ragazzi io farei una serie tv
solo con questo nome
american trumpet domani prima puntata esatto
trombetta americana bellissimo allora
microfono note musicali singin in the rain
- - -
ah vale anche quella però in che senso
vai le emoji sono molto belle
secondo me ma é facilissima guns and roses
pistole e rose gruppo musicale
ok difficile aspetta devo farla vedere allora neve e un bambino e neve questa è ghiaccio
piú ghiaccio
sto diventando brava anche io dopo 700 aiuti che gli
ho dato snow ice é una canzone
amo letterale ice child ice ice baby
- - -
questa qui è facile dalle emoji non
così tanto eh pugno e asso pugno fiore
punch flower no era fight club
ho capito ma il pugno
scusami club scusatemi club questo adesso adesso vedi
vai non facile di più
beh il re leone lion king in inglese the lion king
e qui vi canteremo è una giostra che va
dah dai anche questa conto i secondi
vado alla ricerca di nemo mmmmm prego un bicchiere di vino è un distributore dai
ti aiuto é una persona vin diesel bravo
ti stavo per dire chiedi l'aiuto perché questo
la indovinano subito facile una canzone no
baila dance note peach no non é
nessuna di queste parole ti descrive
qualcosa non è un detto una cultura
generale cultura pop tiktok
era twerk beh dai raga si capiva no twerk la musica il sedere che si muove su e giù dai non è vero
ahhh adesso ridiamo beach boys no
questa l'avevi letta i beach boys gruppo
famosissimo anni 80
vabbè questa è facile facile
posso vedere orange is the new black yaaas facile e bello bello
cos'è una canzone più o meno un gruppo
chiedilo a casa perché questa veramente cioé
allora decido di mandarla a un mio amico
andrea andre mi devi aiutare in questo
gioco devo indovinare la parola che si
cela dietro questo rebus e mi devi
aiutare é facile di che cosa si tratta
è online tra l'altro perché stavo per dire
se non la legge stiamo qua fino a dopodomani sta registrando un audio " vabe ovvio i Coldplay"  era facile infatti non
capivo perché non la indovinassi non facilissima ma potresti
arrivarci
ho capito ho capito quello che faceva sean
connery non mi viene il titolo cavolo inghilterra cavolo non mi viene
io chiedo l'aiuto allora lo sto
chiedendo ai miei maryners quindi ho
scritto è un film quale c'è ti giuro io lo
so qual è non mi viene il titolo proprio
é famosissimo
007  giusto perché hai fatto quella faccia però si chiama
così james bond
e vabbè dai comunque ragazzi
teamjonasitaly mi ha riposto la prima
guardate prima risposta 007 top è facile
american pie dai perché così facile a lui
questa probabilmente cosa cosa dai doctor house no hai sbagliato cavolo doctor who
guarda un pó top gun
speravo che questa lo mettesse in
difficoltà
bella questa posso vedere back case e
bambini un po biondi un po mori é una cosa
che puó sapere tipo salvo gliela mandiamo chiedo
l'aiuto a casa é una cosa un po anni
90 barra 2000 e nell'ambito diamogli un aiuto
musicale per ora non risponde per ora é brain storming ci sta
pensando
ok non è più online
esatto non è molto collaborativo mi ha
scritto dimmi subito che devo vincere
mettiamogli un pó di ansia giustamente se
no lui non ha idea del video che
stiamo girando quindi magari dice vabbé le rispondo dopo bene salvo non
risponde quindi a questo punto se me lo consenti io la sposterei sulle domande
instagram perché sono più persone
presenti
allora per adesso ho alcune risposte ma
in particolare una mi ha fatto capire
che sono una cretina perché era non
facile di più e cioè facciamoli vedere
sono ovviamente i backstreet boys mi é
caduto il telefono vediamo una chiave un
pulmino te lo dico subito ti aiuto è un
attore mi hai dato un aiuto
infatti sono proprio brava ma tanto
allora ti posso dire che uno dei miei
film preferiti che ha fatto lui é american
beauty bellissimo mi è piaciuto
tantissimo risposta kevin spacey che tra
l'altro è abbastanza difficilino perché
era key van questo é van key van space sea
cioè proprio letterale
pollo hamburger pizza e videogiochi
giocare ai videogiochi mangiando certo no
allora aiuto è un film queste cosa sono
cibo cibo perché
food games ce l'ho hunger games questa
grazie la metto qui grazie ultima ultima
carta cos'è questo video giochi tipo
sul cesso i famosissimi videogiochi
sul cesso il cesso lo devi vedere più
metaforico sì insomma chiedi aiuto
su Instagram che non l'hai ancora chiesto si secondo me indovinano domanda scrivi
rebus rebus che telefilm é ancora che
lo aiuto eh tra l'altro allora mi è
arrivata una risposta game of thrones
sembra un pó strano amo é game of thrones
certo come ti sembra strano scusami game il trono non c'era il trono l'emoji e il trono per eccellenza che
abbiamo tutti a casa è il signor sesso
quindi game of thrones
allora adesso non ci resta che contare
mi raccomando non barare
allora ognuno le conta ma non dice il
numero 1 2 3 diciamo 123 18 cosa non è
vero no vabbè ragazzi questa cosa è
allucinante
io ero convinta che fossi in vantaggio tu
anche io credevo di essere in vantaggio
io poi soprattutto cosa vinciamo
l'incoronazione aspetta aspettami qui
allora ragazzi questa è
l'incoronazione per la parità mi sembra
giusto così alle regine la corona e ai re
la corona a forma di cuffia io direi che
così possiamo concludere il video vi
ricordo se non l'avete ancora fatto e se
vi è piaciuto questo video di iscrivervi al
canale e di cliccare sulla campanella
vicino al tasso d'iscrizione per
ricevere le notifiche tutte le volte che
pubblico un video e di seguirmi su
tutti gli altri social facebook e
instagram e tiktok e se volete seguire
anche su instagram edo lui si chiama
edoardoquaranta quindi seguiteci vi mando vi
mandiamo un bacione speriamo che il
video vi sia piaciuto
e chi lo sa magari ne faremo un altro
la rivincita certo
perché la parità é bella siamo contenti
ma noi vogliamo di più
vogliamo tutto e ce lo andremo a prendere
al prossimo video